in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Kyle
and Jamie are with us hey guys how are
you doing great Dave doing great
welcome welcome good to have you where
do you guys live are in the DC area Oh
fun welcome to Nashville Thanks so
you're here to do a debt-free scream I
love it I love it how much have you paid
off and paid off 85 grand all right how
long did that take you
28 months well done making what kind of
money started out 60 now currently
around 72 that doesn't include a housing
fund that we get okay very cool housing
fun you're in the military I guess by
the haircut all right well no but the
housing fund watch which branch of the
Marine Corps okay
well thank you for your service thank
very cool so you do that and Jamie do
you work outside the home no I get to be
a stay-at-home mom oh that's awesome
okay and the three kiddos are here with
us running around they'll join you when
you get ready to the debt-free scream I
hope absolutely yeah Chesney and Trenton
and autumn are how old for two and
almost 100 you got lots of little ones
you got your hands full mom okay very
cool so what kind of debt was this
$85,000 a little bit of everything we
had student loans cars credit cards
bedrooms
like I said a little bit of everything
never met it that we didn't like so
you're normal absolutely absolutely
full-blooded Americans all right very
cool which was the biggest debt now
student loans ah how much of the 85 was
that about 45 so over half then okay Wow
so Jamie what happened 28 months ago um
well that's actually Kyle's story I just
know he came home and uh told me hey we
should check out this Dave Ramsey and uh
listen to his DVD and buy his book but
I'll let him expand a little bit more
okay yeah I worked with a guy a very
sharp guy but he drove this beater car
around but he was so proud of it because
it was paid off and he called him one
day said his transmission broke he's
more stressed out about being late to
work than the transmission blow and he
said I just actually play it still
planning on going out that weekend and
buying a handgun only you know he'd
already been already been mentioned in
you throughout the time I was working
with them and so I thought there's
something to it
went down the chaplains office and
borrowed the military edition identity
view that she put out and you started
going down the list of stupid things
that people do with their money and I
was like yep check check
yeah done that got my t-shirt for that
one I was like there's something to this
we got to try it out okay cool so you
decide to go home and talk to Jamie
about it and what was were you receptive
Jamie or you're like yeah I'd like to
get out that but all this is kind of
sounds weird or what I actually told him
I actually asked him if he was sure that
we should spend the hundred and fifty
dollars for the home study kit yeah that
was a good idea um because it felt like
at the time that things maybe he just
for kind of you think kind of tight yeah
you're trying to raise three kids just
trying to make sure everything's
happening at home and this guy comes
home with this bright idea to spend
money to get out of debt that seems
backward I don't blame you that's
exactly right good for you
okay that's what I would have done so so
you bought the home study kit we did we
did and then the two of you went through
it and so at what point in the process
then did you start to realize this might
work I'd say once we got our first debt
paid off setting up the baby step one
move the emergency fund was pretty
pretty easy I think that was done you
know within a couple days yeah but um
yeah once we had the first step paid off
and then things kind of got rolling and
rolling and rolling further you get into
that more you believe absolutely yeah
very cool very cool so Kyle what was the
hardest part of this for you uh getting
rid of the toys at first but oh yeah the
social media the what you say Harley
Davidson Road King Classic guys still
still talk to me about bass boat what my
Jeep your Jeep oh so he didn't just sell
this stuff you sold some of your stuff
okay yeah all right so what are you
driving now Jamie we drive a six Dondre
yeah okay I sold I sold the ha this was
why the guys gave me so much beef but I
sold the Harley
I was able to pay that off and then use
the rest of it to buy an a.1 Honda
Accord yeah my Dave car but I'm I
wouldn't trade that for anything I love
that car now you're now you're the guy
that is smart with money and everybody's
asking about this stuff that's why
they're giving you a hard time about
exams Ellis your car not really they're
just jealous of you winning yeah yeah
very fun there was one thing where we
had finished watching I think it's
serious season all season for him a week
for the dumping day and you're running
across the stage you know telling you to
sell everything I thought we were pumped
up on the couch listing everything we're
going off and I looked over in the
kitchen
I'm sorry the dining room and saw this
dining table that I bought her for her
birthday and I was like you know we
could probably get a couple hundred
bucks all of that and she looked at me
and she said maybe you should pray about
that I'm telling you all those years hey
Bea I think we need a bass food I think
a motorcycle justifying everything and
she kept saying they were going to pray
a lot it finally clicked that means no
way
maybe we should pray about it is you're
not being smart that's code for dummy
listen yeah I love it that's fun
very cool well congratulations y'all how
does it feel now good I wouldn't trade
any of those toys for anything it's uh
you know peace knowing that we have a
you know can build a strong future for
our family and our three kids will grow
up learning how to manage money and you
know have a bright future as well yeah
absolutely completely change the family
tree very cool so what advice do you
give now when people find out you've
paid off $85,000 worth a debt how do you
tell them you did that what are the keys
to getting out of debt I definitely have
a budget and work together as a team I
think that was the biggest hope before
we really weren't communicating much
about money or spending and then once we
were it was and had it put down on paper
it was much easier to follow and keep
each other accountable for - okay very
cool what about you Joe uh I mean I
would say being willing to look long
term being willing to sacrifice short
term and the long term good yeah that's
that was key for me I was living like no
one else so that later you get to live
and give like no one else I've heard
that before yeah you get those three
little babies and you've completely
changed your family tree you guys are
heroes thank you you really are and we
appreciate your service to the country
the answer thank you very much
absolutely incredible all right Kyle and
Jamie Chesney trenton and autumn are in
the background in the bookstore hanging
out are you gonna bring them up Oh we'd
love to yeah poor old city's gonna blow
your speaker's out Oh we'll get him up
there Miss Dorothy and we'll get them
going because we get them on shot for
the camera as well a beautiful family
wow how cute that's fun
I need a dinosaur dinosaur in a while
I think grandpa's out I have a dinosaur
what are you alright alright Kyle and
Jamie Chesney Trenton in the autumn from
Washington DC
$85,000 paid off in twenty eight months
making sixty to seventy two thousand
dollars they sold everything in sight
mainly cause stuff
count it down let's hear a great debt
free scream here we go three two one
yes great job you guys absolutely very
very well done that's how you do it
right there no question about it very
fun you guys would be so rich so fast
and be able to do so much not only for
yourselves and for your family but for
others